voici bientôt trois mois que vous menez
une campagne extrêmement active sur le
terrain vous avez sillonné la france
entière le territoire métropolitain mais
aussi les départements et les
territoires d'outre-mer vous avez tenu
de multiples réunions vous avez
rencontré beaucoup de gens comment au
moment où cette campagne s'achève
pratiquement pourriez vous résumer votre
impression générale sur ce que pensent
les français
eh bien j'ai d'abord constaté que les
deux candidats qui étaient déjà présents
en 1974 n'ont su ni convaincre ni
entraîner les français et j'ai constaté
au contraire que ma candidature que y
ait un accord un soutien le chaque jour
plus important vous avez une explication
à ce double mouvement l'un de monter et
l'autre de stagnation
je crois que cela tient au fait que les
français ressentent actuellement une
espèce de découragement de malaise
ils n'ont pas été mobilisés et ce
découragement et ce malaise viennent je
crois du fait qu'il faut aujourd'hui les
gouvernés autrement c'est-à-dire en leur
donnant à la fois plus de
responsabilités plus de liberté mais
aussi en leur donnant le sentiment que
leurs affaires intérieures et
extérieures sont traités avec plus de
fermeté je crois que c'est ça le
problème
vous ne croyez pas que la raison
essentielle de ce malaise prenons le mot
c'est quand même quelque chose de
beaucoup plus concret le chômage par
exemple qui touche toutes les familles
oui naturellement le chômage c'est
d'ailleurs le point central de toute la
politique que je propose aux français et
qui consiste à lutter contre le chômage
a augmenté la production
mais au delà de ce problème il y en a un
autre qui et comment dirais je ressentis
confusément et qu'ils aient le sentiment
qu'on les français d'une certaine
inutilité si j'ose dire c'est à dire le
sentiment que
problèmes quotidiens ne sont pas compris
que leurs suggestions ne sont pas
entendus qu'il n'y a pas de dialogue
entre eux et les pouvoirs publics ceux
qui sont responsables des affaires de la
nation qu'il n'ya pas en un mot de
concertation et comment est-ce que cela
se passerait concrètement si vous étiez
du comment vous y prendriez vous pour
faire comprendre aux français qu'ils
sont pris en considération car c'est un
peu ça votre objectif mais je crois que
c'est d'abord et avant tout une question
d'état d'esprit
si vous me permettez je reprendrai un
exemple qui était celui de mon
expérience comme ministre de
l'agriculture je n'ai jamais à cette
époque pris une seule décision qui n'ait
été au préalable prise en accord avec
l'ensemble des représentants des
organisations agricoles alors
naturellement ça demande du temps ça
demande un effort de compréhension
mutuelle ce n'est pas simplement un
dialogue où chacun s'exprime et où
ensuite de l'état décide c'est
véritablement l'exigence d'une meilleure
compréhension mutuelle
est ce qu'il y à d'autres catégories
sociales qui seraient concernées par
cette politique de concertation à
deviner mais tout bien entendu
prenons quelques exemples vous avez
aujourd'hui les les cadres je veux dire
l'ensemble du personnel dans le cadre
mans c'est à dire cadres et agents de
maîtrise qui savent qu'ils sont
l'ossature même de la nation qu'ils sont
responsables de son avenir de son
activité et qui ont le sentiment à la
fois d'être mal à l'aise dans leur
entreprise malgré bien sûr des
exceptions mais surtout de ne pas être
considéré compris entendu de ne pas
pouvoir dialoguer normalement avec les
pouvoirs publics sur des problèmes qui
sont à l'évidence même de leurs
compétences et de leurs responsabilités
vous avez les professions libérales
on explique aujourd'hui en permanence
que nous sommes pour une société de
liberté d'initiative de responsabilité
et on laisse petit à petit
marginaliser les professions libérales
on ne leur donne pas la faculté de
s'épanouir au contraire on les en
permanence on fait en sorte qu'elle ne
soit pas libres de leurs mouvements
il faut là aussi avoir un véritable
dialogue avec elle je condamne un
dernier exemple qui sont les
fonctionnaires le problème des
fonctionnaires aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
d'en créer davantage le problème c'est
de leur donner plus de sens des
responsabilités les convaincre qu'ils
sont au service de la nation et leur
donnait bien entendu institue une
considération qui leur revient
prenez par exemple les instituteurs il
est extraordinaire que ce corps qui a
tant fait pour le pays et qui sous la
troisième république notamment est
encore sous la ivème a forgé en quelque
sorte la république aujourd'hui se
sentent aussi mal à l'aise et que le
dialogue entre eux et les pouvoirs
publics soit devenu une sorte de
dialogue de sourds qu'il faut
aujourd'hui que l'on se comprenne mieux
je ne dis pas qu'il faut leur donner
satisfaction surtout ce n'est pas le
problème mais il faut se comprendre
mieux et donc discuter davantage prendre
en considération les uns et les autres
les problèmes et les suggestions de
chacun
vous définissez ainsi une sorte de
manière de gouverner différente de ce
qui se pratique à l'heure actuelle mais
je me demande si dans cette impression
de malaise que vous avez ressenti
il n'y a pas quelque chose dont on parle
moins souvent mais qui est une espèce
d'inquiétude sourde
les françaises et les français devant la
façon dont les affaires de la france
sont conduites à l'extérieur dont la
france contribue aujourd'hui au
développement de la paix dans le monde
oui encore que les français n'ont jamais
pris exactement conscience des
conséquences de la politique étrangère
sur leur vie quotidienne
mais aujourd'hui ils se rendent compte
davantage de cet important
il faut dans une politique étrangère une
très grande fermeté
il la faut d'abord pour défendre les
intérêts de notre pays
on ne peut pas dire aujourd'hui par
exemple que à bruxelles au sein de la
communauté européenne la france est
suffisamment d'autorité et de volonté
pour défendre les intérêts de nos
agriculteurs de nos marins pêcheurs de
nos sidérurgiste de nos travailleurs de
l'industrie du textile ou d'autres c'est
sans doute un domaine d'un politique
étrangère où il est facile on le voit
c'est aussi de critiquer il est plus
difficile de proposer et quelles
seraient les fondements d'une politique
étrangère que vous pourriez bonne et si
vous étiez élu bien ce fondement je
crois sont simples il ya d'abord le fait
qu'il faut toujours avoir le même
langage
quel que soit l'interlocuteur auquel on
s'adresse
il faut ensuite être profondément
convaincu que lorsque les intérêts de la
france et des français sont en jeu le
compromis ou la concession n'est pas
acceptable
il faut enfin savoir que la france a
traditionnellement un message à apporter
au monde et à cet égard une
responsabilité à l'égard des autres
nations et que ce message c'est la
défense intransigeante des droits de
l'homme des droits des peuples à
disposer d'eux mêmes et sur ces domaines
la france ne doit pas accepter de
concessions l'un des moyens de cette
politique étrangère particulièrement
résolu et active c'est la présence des
français à l'étranger est également la
présence de la france sous une forme qui
est très importante qui était celle de
sa longue
oui c'est exact la france a le privilège
d'être présente au monde un peu partout
d'abord géographiquement par ces
départements d'outre-mer ces territoires
d'outre-mer qui font qu'elle n'est pas
un pays comme les autres
replié sur son hexagone d'où
l'importance de ces régions
la france ensuite à beaucoup d'hommes et
de femmes auxquelles je tiens
particulièrement aujourd'hui à rendre
hommage et qui la représente sur le plan
économique social culturel un peu
partout dans le monde la france a cette
chance extraordinaire d'avoir une langue
et une culture internationale et
d'ailleurs elle ne défend pas ses sept
langues et cette culture il faut avoir
une politique beaucoup plus dynamique de
défense de la langue française dans le
monde
et puis il ya enfin les problèmes qu'il
ne faut pas oublier qu'ils sont liés à
sa défense on en parle assez peu dans
cette campagne électorale est ce que
vous pourriez nous préciser un peu quels
sont les grands axes de votre politique
de défense y est la dissuasion d'abord
bien entendu et la défense d'abord est
liée à la politique étrangère une
politique étrangère qui veut sauvegarder
la paix doit être une politique de
fermeté lorsque les pays occidentaux ont
marqué leur fermeté la détente s'est
développée et la paix s'est affirmée
lorsqu au contraire comme l'a dénoncé
il y a trois ou quatre ans monsieur
soljenitsyne les pays occidentaux ont
voulu discuter concédé compromettre
alors ras les russes puisque c'est d'eux
qu'il s'agit du helmand ont pris un
certain nombre d'initiatives pour
pousser leur avantage et ça remette en
cause à la fois la détente et la paix on
le voit bien aujourd'hui il faut donc
plus de fermeté et cette fermeté
s'appuient notamment sur l'existence
d'une défense nationale qui soit
véritablement efficace pour l'efficacité
aujourd'hui et plus personne ne le
conteste
c'est la défense nucléaire et notamment
la composante de notre défense du pire
qui est la moins vulnérables
c'est-à-dire celles qui se trouvent sous
les mers nos sous marins nucléaires
c'est pourquoi je propose d'augmenter
notre effort en ce qui concerne les sous
marins nucléaires
il faut pouvoir
montrer sa force pour ne pas avoir à
s'en servir
ça aussi c'est le service d'une
politique de paix dans cet effort de
défense vous parlez beaucoup du
nucléaire il ya aussi une autre
composante car la france a des voies
d'approvisionnement à protéger les à vis
de l'étranger elle a besoin d'une force
d'intervention est ce qu'il n'ya pas là
aussi quelques problèmes à l'heure
actuelle certainement on pourrait
évoquer naturellement tous ces problèmes
non seulement elle a des voies
d'approvisionnement à protéger les ailes
à des accords oui mais aussi est là les
accords avec un certain nombre de pays
je pense en particulier avec l'afrique
qui sont les accords de défense et
qu'elle doit être en état de respecter
et cela suppose que ces forces
d'intervention soit demain doté de ce
qui leur manque c'est à dire des moyens
matériels et notamment des moyens de
transport qui lui sont pas dispensés
alors monsieur chirac devant un monde
aussi dangereux aussi compliqué devant
une tâche aussi lourde que celle qui
vous attend si vous êtes élu est ce que
vous êtes optimiste ou pessimiste je
suis optimiste je le suis d'abord parce
que c'est dans ma nature je le suis
ensuite parce que lorsqu'on veut
gouverner un pays on n'a pas le droit
d'être pessimiste et je le suis enfin
parce que j'ai profondément confiance
dans la capacité de la france qui est un
grand pays qui n'est pas un pour cent
dans le monde a surmonté ses problèmes
et qui demain comme hier sera un grand
pays
en tous les cas pour ma part je ferai en
sorte si je suis élu que les français
soient à la fois fiers et heureux d'être
français